it's easy to remember the flashy plays
in
siege those clutch 1v3 plays that leave
you wondering
was that player even human but today we
wanted to take a look
at some of the more sophisticated plays
in siege the plays that flex the most
important muscle
in the human body the brain the plays
that leave viewers thinking
damn that's genius
this is the count of the theatrical
this is the most 200 iq play
i have ever seen so here we go then
here are the top 10 200 iq plays
in rainbow six siege
opening today's list we have a sneaky
counter defuse from the semi-finals of
pro league season 10.
everyone from reciprocity throwing
bodies to the grave but
wrestlemania neck and neck in the first
map versus team reciprocity
navi looked like they were poised to
take the lead and reach
match point but just as they were about
to
they were hit with a nasty surprise
toxic babe at the very last second
but it's not going to do very much
damage they have to lock things down
nello going to get tagged up he's
actually going to be down and it's going
to be an equal trade here as retro gets
confirmed inside the kitchen
crawls away to safety though is nello do
they know he's down it's gonna be a
rotate but citizens on yellow
it seems like the man practically lives
here three fires once again but
reciprocity
no one's watching what just happened
while navi were mowing down his
teammates foxes
slipped behind enemy lines to pull off
the 200 iq
ninja defuse leaving everyone stunned
taking the number 9 spot on alice is an
example of how sometimes
not taking the shot is the smartest
thing you can do
when you're in that position to strike
and you hesitate for that moment you
have
two real options you either pay for it
immediately
or you fully capitalize and wow
stuck in a 1v4 sparks options were
limited
so when a free kill presented itself
you'd think he'd jump on the opportunity
but instead of flexing his trigger
finger he flexed his brain
and waited for a bigger reward and again
still a defender in the site and that's
going to be uno who gets bibu
and as spark gets pushed on he is very
wisely not getting the initial fracking
the treadmill kell
wilkie now with a one versus one he
might have the yokai still but it's a
post-plant situation and half of the
diffuser has been whittled down
spark is in a perfect spot to clutch
this right now
and then to truly reward his massive
brain
ants gives him the clutch here it comes
wilkie checks the wrong
angle and he goes back in for the
diffuser there's no time
spark clutches it out in a one versus
four
coming in at number eight we have a
moment of accidental brilliance coming
out from shangri
finding himself in a 1v1 situation he
chucked a nade at red groove and he
missed
or did he he's right next to you
oh my god goes in for it red groove gets
one kill he's low in hp
equal to shangri is playing from behind
the ventilation does he dive out red
crew has to try to play it
he can throw it out red groove will try
to hold it grenade's going to be cooked
here red groove will continue to stop
runs right on the position and shangri
what a what a kobe play
that was kobe the fact that
actually worked what the 10 000
iq failure at number seven we have a
classic play from the 2018
six invitational grand finals one map
away from
tournament elimination eg's canadian
found himself in a 1v1 with pentastar
pengu we'll have to out duel two of the
best operators on attack near canadian
working away at the wall
nbk takes one down that's all up to
pengu who takes that nbk it's 1v1
canadian has four kills defuser going
off canadian will need an ace
in order to stick this through off of
the plan he goes he'll just waste
time and evil geniuses
pengu was in the middle of planting so
canadian employed a
classic 200 iq strategy that we like to
call
made you look aces takes the number six
spot on today's list with a play from
last year's allied esports vegas miner
alone versus two players from team
secret aces needed to prevent a plant
and he did it with the smartest rotation
you will
ever see all up to aces inside of blue
barrel and funkers last two alive is
asus will kill the man with a defuser
sprints upstairs funkers has to try and
grab this diffuser that's exactly what
he's going to do he's on hot mark as
he's going to drop back in blue
what a 200 iq played by aces rotates
around
gonna kill the man on black box aces ice
in this man's veins right now in round
number nine
coming in at the halfway point on our
list is cloud nine's
mark who pulled off a genius play back
at dreamhack montreal 2018.
locked in combat with mocker esports sir
boss mark found his frag with a nitro
cell play that's
basically out tom and jerry panix who's
just been
unable to get it going i think to the
extent that we anticipate
sir boss trying to fight on those visa
stairs but mark is gonna
miss but he gets it anyway mr
boss runs right into him oh
mark you can't say that wasn't planned
thankfully cloud9 didn't squander mark's
ingenious move
and secured the round
number four on this list is a pretty
crafty play from doodle during season 10
of n a pro league things look to be dire
for doodle as he was faced with a
potential 2v1 but as laxing picked up
his
downed teammate doodle sent team
reciprocity his regards from below
with a nasty surprise relaxing
absolutely on fire
in a one versus one he's gonna pick up
his teammate but below doodle has the
impact and it's poorly tied
perfectly timed in fact from below a
double impact kill
and doodle will salvage the round
oh no reciprocity how often do you see a
double impact kill probably
closer than ever yeah yeah that was
whoo and number three play takes us all
the way to siege's collegiate league
where players study hard to make plays
like this one from pandemonium he
literally used his body to hide an
explosive surprise
right by the bomb pandemonium in a 1v1
with the diffuser down
oh take it down watch for this claymore
yeah he's going to cover it up oh the
claymore that's enough
pandemonium slides in front of the
claymore look at that
you can't see the players here stay in
school kids because
if you do you might get smart enough to
pull off a 200 iq play
just like that taking our runner-up spot
is a 200 iq
play pulled off in the most challenging
of circumstances
of 1v3 during the grand finals of the
2026
invitational with only a few seconds
left in the round
space station gaming's rampage
maneuvered himself around
three nip players to stop the plant from
below
with a clutch takes impact grenade
diffuser won't go down 10 seconds left
bosco can't get out of there now
everybody's falling it's a 3v1
somebody from nip will need to plant
it's pinot's job to do that
rampy down below will he be able to stop
this in time he has an impact
here it is bound control to major tom
we've got ourselves a series
match point for space station
it's a play so good we literally named
it our 2020 play of the year
but there's just one siege play that's
smarter
topping today's list is a legendary play
from team empire scyther
at the 2019 rally major so picture this
you're stuck in a 1v1 and need to
counter the fuse
the only problem is that the other guy
has his eyes on the diffuser
and will just fill you with bullets if
you even try and get close
so how do you do it well if you're
scyther you just remember that hey
you're playing siege and shoot straight
through the wall to make your
own path to the bomb now that's true
genius now scyther has to pick up the
mantle here less than half the time
remaining in order to get under the
diffuser here amiibe is gonna be spot on
the outside scyther
takes the duel and wins it but now is
the hard part now he's going to deal
with the player upstairs and this is not
going to be an easy factor at all he
does not have the nitrous still to
confirm the easy kill
oh oh what is this there's no way that
leon's gonna be able to read into this
maybe he has no
he's noticed that the nade goes in
an empire 3 billion iq from scyther
to clutch out the round well there you
go guys those were some crazy plays from
rainbow six
siege which one of those was your
favorite also i'm going to ask you to
hit that subscribe button
if you haven't done so already we here
at the score esports are on the way
to 2 million subscribers an absolutely
incredible number
so hopefully you can help us get there
if you haven't subscribed already
thanks for watching and i'll see you all
in the next one
well now you've got the uh you've got
the grenades
and uh you're throwing the grenades in
you're looking for a
lovely weave flag and um
rainbow six siege you like ash
ash although although i often get banned
from twitch chat when i say ash
and i i i i don't have any idea why
i have no idea what to keep banning me
for saying ash it's just ash
i love ash